des messages d'encouragement et des
renforts pour le personnel des
résidences pour aînés 250 soldats sont
venus prêter main forte dans cinq
centres du grand toronto investigating
paris
selon cet employé la province doit en
faire plus et enquêter en profondeur
pour déterminer les besoins réels dans
les foyers d'éclosion la santé publique
ontarienne rapportent des cas de kobe 19
dans 167 centres de soins de longue
durée
près de 460 personnes qui seraient
mortes de la maladie des données
incomplètes et publiée en retard selon
la coalition ontarienne pour la santé
une sous-évaluation de la crise ce
groupe de pression a mené sa propre
enquête auprès des 35 instances locales
de santé publique en ontario ils
auraient découvert ou moins 1000 cas
d'infection
de plus on revient encore aux carences
dans le dépistage en ontario et selon ce
spécialiste il soutient qu'à peine 20 %
des résidents et employés des centres de
soins de longue durée ont été testés
selon lui plusieurs décès n'ont pas été
classées comme étant relié à la coved 19
en raison du manque de test
la proportion des décès dans les
résidences comparativement à l'ensemble
des morts causées par la coved 19 est
semblable au québec et en ontario à plus
de 60%
le docteur storl crois qu'il faut
s'attendre à une hausse des décès
compilées en ontario puisque tous les
résidents et employés des foyers seront
dorénavant tester les twin towers
on commence à faire ce qu'on réclamait
depuis des semaines répond elle
la crise risque de s'intensifier à court
terme en ontario selon ces experts les
employés des centres de soins de longue
durée pourrait avoir besoin de renforts
supplémentaires ici philippe leblanc
radio canada toronto